يوم واحد بيفصلنا عن الزفاف الملكي
الاردني المنتظر زفاف ولي العهد الامير او
زبوليل العهد الاردني الامير الحسين من
السعوديه رجوى السيف والتحضيرات
والتجهيزات للزفاف خلاص في مرحله اللمسات
الاخيره وضيوف الزفاف بداوا بالتوافد من
مختلف دول العالم اليوم الملك عبد الله
بيقيم مادبه عشاء لاربعه الاف شخصيه
اردنيه وبكره رح تتم مراسم عقد القران في
قصر زهران بعدها بتنطلق مسيره الموكب
الملكي الاحمر اللي راح يجوب شوارع عمان
اللي تزينت بهذه المناسبه وراح يمر بالسبع
مواقع مخصصه للاحتفالات وصولا الى قصر
الحسينيه اللي راح يكون في العشاء وحفل
الزفاف وللي بيسال ايش الموكب الملكي
الاحمر فهو تقليد ملكي عريق موجود من وقت
تاسيس الدوله وبيتكون من عشرين سياره
حمراء مكشوفه ذات طابع كلاسيكي 14 منها
بتستخدم في الموكب وفي ست احتياط
وبترافقها عشر دراجات ناريه وبيستقلوا 71
فرد من الحرس الملكي بيلبسوا اوشحه حمراء
على صدورهم ولباس الجيش والكوفيه الحمراء
وهذا الموكب عاده يستخدم في الاعياد
والمناسبات الوطنيه مثل عيد الاستقلال
وخطاب العرش السامي واي زفاف ملكي وكانت
بدات بروفات مسيره الموكب الاحمر في شوارع
العاصمه من امس
[موسيقى]
وكمان من بين التحضيرات ومظاهر الاحتفال
بوليه العهد الاردني الاغاني اللي لازالت
مستمره واللي كثير من الفنانين العرب
اهدوها للامير الحسين والانسه
يوم الفرح يوم السعد زينوا الوطن رش الورد
عرسي فارس
هاشمير
وجاب الف مبروك
لاميرك قلوبنا
الهاشمي واللي راكبين الحالي نمشي على
هقويتك يا حلمانه لبالي وانت العالي
بتستاهل والحاضر
وانت العادي
والحازم اله يا حسين يا الكفو معك الشاعر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الورد والحنه على
عروسنا يا ولي العهد حنه بيك مرفوع عروسنا
في العرب
اسياد القوم رجوى القلب المثلى ما
بيتلاقوا كل يوم
[موسيقى]
والعرب كبير فرحتهم الاردن الرجال وبواسل
الملك عبد الله اولهم والمملكه
الهاشميه
عروبتها مبروك للعرسان طبعا انا احب
الافراح على العموم مشاهدينا طبعا بكره
اليوم المنتظر واكيد حنتابعوه في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
الحانوت سيدي عبد الله يا ابن الهوى